I'll start at the beginning my whole
family was killed in a car accident
someone did horrific experiments on me I
was abducted raped and forced to kill
someone and I'm in here bouncing oh God
so how was anger-management still angry
some people call me a hero
others call me a freak you're one of
them [ __ ] I didn't ask for this I'm
just trying to make a goddamn living in
this goddamn City you API I'm
resourceful people I care about are in
danger I gotta make a decision one keep
denying it Sartre to do something about
it we belong way down below
I don't know how you handle it's called
a whiskey
[Applause]
[ __ ] call me a [ __ ] again Jessica
Jones you are a hard-drinking
short-fused mess
anything bad Miss Jones
yeah I always see what threats head-on
meaning I punch them in the head until
they're unconscious
[Music]
everybody is Charlie we got new Jessica
Jones season two to break down and a big
update on daredevil season three and if
you didn't know it's actually premiering
March 8th I will do videos for the
season just depending on interest level
so if you guys want a whole bunch of
Easter Egg videos or if you just want F
Assad videos no worries the footage here
is mostly season 2 season 1 and
defenders footage cut with that
voiceover from her just kind of linking
together the slow ramping up to her
losing her [ __ ] season 1 was mostly
about her getting to the point where she
was capable of interacting with the
outside world like she completely shut
herself up defenders was hurt learning
to work with the group again like in
that season 2 footage you see her in
that group therapy session bouncing the
goddamn ball as she calls it the events
of season 2 is her actually dealing with
some of her past like she talks about
the origin story you get a much better
picture of that crash that killed her
parents so it'll be interesting to see
how they filmed that from what
perspective like if she's walking
through it the way that iron man can
manipulate his own memories and walk
through them when he's BA are effing by
nearly augmented retro framing or barf
God I got to work on that acronym these
shots are the high-rises that you see or
her link to jeryn hogarth jeryn hogarth
is kind of like the central figure in a
lot of these series just because she's
in Midtown Dan a trans in Midtown but
she also crosses over with daredevil
because foggy is now working at her law
firm obviously she's coming back during
Jessica Jones season 2 but we also see
her on one of these high-rises looking
at an apartment building taking pictures
of what looks like this character here
who comes to talk to her about either
merging their detective businesses or
maybe he's getting really territorial
about his business but he's just the
person who tells her that I also do
investigations the way that she does but
he kind of seems like an antagonist
because later you see her throwing him
through this glass door and we also get
a lot more shots of that ferris-wheel
scene where it looks like she's throwing
another woman who's either in antagonist
or one of the other enhance people the
freaks as she calls them like they play
that scene from defenders where she's
lifting that douchebags car up and he's
like you're one of them you're one of
those freaks
most of the kilgrave that you see in the
trailer is stuff from season 1 there's
like a little bit of season 2 cut in
here but the only real new footage
scene of him was when he was slow
clapping on top of that roof and it was
meant to imply that he's just in her
mind like he's not actually back from
the dead I've always liked the way that
Bendis and now the TV show obviously
doing Ben disses comic-book thing of
putting her in this purple state of mind
just to let you know what's going on
usually anytime there's purple it's
either commenting on what she's thinking
about or is her hallucinating something
that happened in the past so they use
false narration in this really
interesting way which i think is gonna
be fun for David Tennant during season 2
is this her own self-doubt speaking to
her or is it really some vestige of him
left inside her mind because remember
the way his power worked it was like
this crazy pheromone and he would
literally dig into your mind
he wasn't straight-up psychic it was
more of a passive ability once you were
within a certain radius you were just
open to suggestions because of the
chemicals that he secreted so like
Jessica said eventually after a period
of time it would wear off but a lot of
that had to do with the duration of time
that you spent in proximity to him so
the longer you're close to him the
longer it takes for that to go away if
she was with him for a really long
period of time in the really messed up
black mirror part of it is that we
learned that they're actually all
conscious while his victims are in his
thrall they're just powerless to do
anything about it
so even when he says do it with a smile
this is a really twisted part about it
even if there's screaming on the inside
every time I see junior Ramirez in the
trailer - I flash back - Wildcat on
arrow if you didn't watch that show he
played the Wildcat character from DC
Comics but they only used him for a
little while because he went to another
TV show and now he's a Jessica Jones
character but aside from him using this
purple paint here on the floor I don't
know that he's necessarily tied to any
of the villains during the season I
think he's just there to be more of a
support character more of a love
interest like somebody that she just
gets into a temporary relationship with
talking about that for those of you
asking what's going on with Luke Cage
they haven't confirmed that he's popping
up during this but they did have that
moment during defenders where they're
like you know maybe we'll get together
and have coffee again sometime
trusting in touch Jess you got friends
one of them is it all but I think for
the most part she's gonna be on her own
I do think they want to tie this to the
other series because even though Jessica
Jones is one of the more loner
characters amongst the defenders like
the most likely to just stay by herself
and not contact other people you already
have foggy gern Hogarth and she's in
Hell's Kitchen which is daredevil
territory so if anybody's gonna cross
over besides Luke Cage it'll be
daredevil characters but for the most
part daredevil is still down for the
count and getting into daredevil season
3 they actually just confirm that Joanne
Whalley is going to be playing sister
Maggie you remember she got the shout
out at the end of daredevil season 3
tell Maggie that he's awake the reason
why that's a really big deal is is
because sister Maggie is actually his
mother in the comics his biological
mother now the circumstances for how
she's going to be used during the season
might be a little bit different but it's
all part of that born-again comic book
arc so when we get a little more
information about daredevil we can
actually talk about comic book story but
I don't want to get into that too soon
just because the TV show changes a lot
of things about the comics the character
description just raises a strong-willed
nun who speaks her mind and cares deeply
about Matt safety so think of her as
like a father Atlanta type characters
somebody who Matt looks to for advice
and guidance but in a more protective
motherly way literally in this case
because Maggie is his mother but if you
didn't see it I did a Luke Cage season 2
video a little while ago because Mike
Colter was at the Black Panther premiere
talking about what they were doing for
season 2 he said that they wrapped a
long time ago so what they'll probably
do is drop a teaser like they used to at
the end of Jessica Jones like after
episode 13 boom here's your first look
at Luke Cage season 2 they haven't
announced to premiere date for that but
I'm expecting it'll be sometime around
Comic Con towards the end of the summer
which means that they'll also have
probably already dropped the daredevil
season 3 teaser as well because they're
still shooting that so they'll probably
just use Comic Con is a big jumping-off
point for anything that's dropping the
second half of the year and obviously
that also
clues all the DC TV shows like Titans
Young Justice season 3 so what I'll do
when it's relevant is I'll just do a
roundup video for when new stuff is
coming because there's like a couple big
things that everybody's really excited
about and they just like a whole bunch
of B level stuff that's interesting but
not necessarily quite as important so no
worries as long as you click the bell
and enabled alerts for my channel you'll
totally see when I post videos and if
you're someone that uses your phone to
watch most of your YouTube videos make
sure every once in a while like at least
a couple times a week you check desktop
because the app will bug out way more
than the desktop interface if you ever
hear people complaining about YouTube
not showing you subscriptions usually
that's mostly the mobile app that
they're complaining about
congratulations to the latest Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway winner dance syndrome
please private message me so I can get
your contact details what'll happen is I
have some new DC to post but leave all
your Marvel bonus video requests in the
comments below there'll be a bunch of
stuff coming up in March a couple series
will be premiering so while you a
birthing click here to learn about how
spider-man and Black Panther are the
keys to Marvel phase four and click here
to learn all about Luke Cage season 2
Heroes for Hire with iron fist thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you